[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue dans le skyco le
magazine qui vous raconte l'actualité
économique du territoire de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines dans ce numéro
nous partirons à la rencontre de
Stéphane lassos directeur général du
groupe émitech il nous fait découvrir le
nouveau centre des cvicules installé à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux décryptage du ski
it c'est le tout nouvel événement qui
réunit les opportunités business pour
les entreprises et des offres d'emploi
pour les jeunes diplômés Céline
l'enfrancy Signol directrice innovation
et enseignement supérieur de
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines nous en dit plus et puis
interview avec Anne fayy la directrice
générale adjointe au développement
économique de Saint-Quentin en Yvelines
elle nous explique le projet porté par
la collectivité et Nokia pour imaginer
les usages de la 5G au Vélodrome
national
[Musique]
bienvenue à imitech je suis Stéphane
Dassault le directeur général émi Tech
notre coeur de métier c'est de réaliser
des essais en environnement sur des
équipements essentiellement
électroniques pour valider leur tenue
leur aptitude a évolué dans
l'environnement pour lequel ils sont
destinés alors quand on parle
d'environnement pour nous ce sont des
revenus climatiques des environnements
mécaniques physico-chimiques acoustique
et la première activité sur laquelle
s'est développée la société Mitek c'est
la compatibilité électromagnétique
[Musique]
cette cage est spécifiquement des années
pour réaliser des tests sur moteur
électrique qui fonctionne en vitesse et
en couple qui va être fixé donc sur
notre banc moteur et on va ainsi pouvoir
réaliser toute notre gamme de tests de
compatibilité électromagnétique
[Musique]
depuis cette salle de contrôle Cédric
pilote tout l'environnement de la cage
de Faraday il mesure les champs
électromagnétiques émis ou reçu par le
moteur c'est à dire qu'il doit ne pas
émettre trop de champ électromagnétiques
pour ne pas perturber les autres
équipements qui sont installés sur le
véhicule et il doit eux-mêmes ne pas
être trop susceptible au champ
électromagnétiques qui peuvent être
générés soit par l'environnement du
véhicule ou soit par un environnement
extérieur tel que des lignes hautes
tension ou des chants radars quand on
passe près d'un aéroport tout ceci est
régi par des normes tous les produits
que nous testons à imitesch sont en
phase prototypes avant leur mise sur le
marché c'est pour ça que le moteur
aujourd'hui nous ne vous le montrons pas
pour des raisons de confidentialité
évidentes vis-à-vis de nos clients
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'automobile le secteur automobile ça
représente 45% du chiffre d'affaires est
Mitek et toutes les nouvelles mobilités
qui se développent aujourd'hui toutes
les nouvelles architectures de véhicules
que ça soit les véhicules électriques à
batterie les hybrides les véhicules
appuie la combustible sont autant
d'opportunités pour le groupe MyTech de
se développer et de réaliser des essais
et nous avons décidé de faire un nouvel
investissement dans une très grande cage
de Faraday pour non plus tester
uniquement des équipements mais des
véhicules complets
[Musique]
Christophe peux-tu nous expliquer les
spécificités de cette cage de Faraday
par rapport à celle dans laquelle nous
étions tout à l'heure où nous testions
des moteurs électriques là on teste un
système dans son intégralité que ce soit
sur des véhicules comme celui-ci mais ça
peut être également sur les véhicules un
peu plus importants comme des bus des
camions ou des utilitaires on est
capable de tester des véhicules
thermiques des véhicules électriques
hybrides et également des véhicules
hydrogène pourquoi doit-on faire des
essais sur ces véhicules avant de les
mettre sur le marché alors la route
l'électronique est particulièrement
sensible aux ondes électromagnétiques
les ondes électromagnétiques on en a un
peu partout on baigne dans un champ
électromagnétiques donc l'idée c'est de
valider un véhicule pour qu'il soit pas
perturbé lorsqu'il va évoluer sur la
route et on va dans un premier temps de
tester tout ce qui est fonctions
sécuritaires et par la suite toutes les
fonctions accessoires du véhicule
[Musique]
pour travailler dans ce nouveau
laboratoire nous avons créé 10 nouveaux
emplois sur notre site de
Montigny-le-Bretonneux d'ailleurs nous
sommes tout le temps en recherche de
talent si vous êtes technicien si vous
êtes ingénieur n'hésitez pas à consulter
notre site internet et rejoignez-nous
[Musique]
bonjour je suis Céline lafrancissignole
directrice innovation et enseignement
supérieur à l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines et je co-organise avec Jean-Luc
mélo l'événement skit
[Musique]
c'est l'événement des innovations et des
talents pour booster vos opportunités
que ce soit en termes d'emploi ou en
termes d'opportunités d'affaires qui se
tiendra dans un lieu unique le vélodrome
national les 19 et 20 avril
[Musique]
pour cet événement on a choisi de faire
un événement beaucoup plus ciblé pour
répondre aux demandes des recruteurs du
territoire et on ne sait notamment
focalisé par exemple sur le job dating
sur un public première expérience mais
qualifiée à partir de bac + 2 jusqu'aux
chercheurs
n'est pas un nouvel événement c'est le
choix de réinventer des événements qui
avaient fait leurs preuves aujourd'hui
mais sur lesquelles on voulait pouvoir
apporter des innovations donc
historiquement ce qui emploie qui se
passait sur une journée dédiée à
l'emploi Vélodrome et le Skype Business
Day et donc on a voulu réunir les deux
étoffer pour vraiment booster toutes les
opportunités pour les entreprises
[Musique]
dans les focus que l'on fait sur cette
édition c'est aussi de mettre en lumière
les filières stratégiques du territoire
qui sont l'aéronautique spatiale défense
la mobilité au sens large le numérique
bien évidemment la santé l'environnement
et l'énergie qui sont voilà vraiment des
drivers pour nos entreprises et pour les
développements d'innovation sur le
territoire
ça se traduira sur les deux jours par la
présence d'un corner JO avec le premier
jour les opportunités
d'emploi notamment avec Pôle Emploi
l'émission locale qui vont venir
présenter les possibilités le deuxième
jour les possibilités business où là on
travaille avec la fabrique des jeux
solidaires pour mettre en exergue et
aider notamment les PME et les
entreprises de l'ESS à se saisir de
toutes les opportunités et puis bien sûr
on présentera très concrètement les JO à
50 ans en Yvelines les épreuves que nous
allons accueillir et puis comment ça
entraîne une dynamique sur le territoire
à travers des conférences et une
émission télé
[Musique]
bonjour Anne failli DGA développement
économique et Smart territoire à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
[Musique]
ce projet on l'a initié en 2019 nous
avons candidaté auprès de l'ARCEP pour
la bande expérimentale 26 giga Hertz
nous l'avons obtenu nous avons ensuite
grâce à l'aide de Nokia développer les
antennes qui permettent de faire
fonctionner cette 5G au Vélodrome et ses
antennes ont été installées l'année
dernière et ont été testés lors des
Championnats du monde de cyclisme
nous souhaitons proposer aux startups
françaises internationales de venir au
vélo de Rome tester leur nouveau service
leur nouvelle application qui ont besoin
de cette infrastructure là pour venir
enrichir l'expérience spectateur que
l'on offrira en 2024 nous avons donc
lancé un appel à projet qui est ouvert
jusqu'au 17 avril pour permettre aux
start-up de venir nous proposer leurs
solutions sur trois champs le premier
c'est celui de l'expérience spectateur
le deuxième c'est celui des médias et le
troisième c'est la gestion du bâtiment
pour un bâtiment plus connecté et plus
sobre sur le plan énergétique
le spectateur va pouvoir prendre ses
propres images de l'événement et va
pouvoir se challenger par rapport à un
athlète il va pouvoir créer un avatar il
va pouvoir lui donner des
caractéristiques de la course et le
mettre en compétition par rapport à la
tête comme ça il devient beaucoup plus
acteur de la de l'événement sportif
7 5G elle permet aux médias
à ceux qui prennent des vidéos au
photographe d'envoyer très très
rapidement leurs images à leur rédaction
et ils peuvent ainsi diffuser en temps
réel ce qu'il se passe sur la piste sans
délai de latence et puis enfin la 5G
c'est un peu plus technique mais elle
permet aussi de mieux gérer le bâtiment
elle permet par exemple d'avoir des
informations sur les réseaux les fluides
tout ce qui est lié au chauffage à l'eau
et elle nous permet d'identifier plus
facilement là où il y a des difficultés
donc d'y répondre plus facilement et
donc d'alléger notre facture en matière
de gestion de bâtiment
merci de nous avoir suivis on se
retrouve bientôt pour un nouveau numéro
du Sky Eco
[Musique]